عندما انسحبت الولايات المتحده قواتها من
افغانستان قبل اكثر من عام كانت تعاهد
طالبان واضحا لا ملاذ للجماعات الارهابيه
ليس تنظيم القاعده فقط وانما توامها
الايديولوجي طالبان باكستان التي تصنفها
واشنطن ارهابيه منذ 2010 لكن ما علاقه
الطالبان باكستان بوعوده نظيرتها
الافغانيه
الحركه الباكستانيه هشه مع اسلام اباد
وقبل الهدنه وبعدها اظهرت الارقام انك
طالبان افغانستان وعددها
والاجابه تاتي من الحدود فقط في الاشهر
الثلاثه الاخيره اكثر مني 250 هجوما انطلق
من افغانستان ابنته طالبان باكستان اي ضعف
عدد العمليات التي نفذتها عام 2020 واكثر
بثلاث مرات من تلك التي نفذتها عام 2019
شرم عوامل اخرى اسهمت في زياده الهجمات
بنسبه 52% منذ الحادي عشر من ابريل الماضي
وهي تولي وهي تولي عفوا احسب شهباز شريف
الحكومه الباكستانيه لا خلافاتنا شريف مع
واشنطن خلافا
لسلفه عمران خان سيناريو اشرف غني في
افغانستان قد يتكرر وبالعوده للهجمات كان
اكثرها في مناطق البشتون ولايه خيبر بخته
نخوه المنطقه الحدوديه المحاديه
لافغانستان من الشمال الغربي
اخرها حادثه احتجاز على يده ثلاثه وثلاثين
سجينا من عناصر طالبان باكستان في مركز
الشرطه في خيبر بخته نخوه المطالب كانت
لافغانستان ولكن الدوله كانت لها كلمتها
قتلت الخاطفين
وحررت الرهائ
اهداف الحركه الباكستانيه كما نظيرتها
تريد ذات الغنائم الاطاحه بحكومه بلادها
وفرض قوانينها الصارمه من بينها حضر
التعليم للفتيات كما فعل الطالبان في
افغانستان قبل ايام وسعود الى هذه النقطه
لاحقا على اسلام اباد ان تقلق قد لا يكون
الامر سهلا عليها كما يعتقد قادتها
تشجع طالبا باكستان لتكرار ما حدث على
الاقل في مناطق البشتون مخاوف السفير
الباكستاني الاسبق لدى واشنطن احسن حقاني
في الخامس عشر من اغسطس عام 2021 عندما
سقطت العاصمه الافنيه كابول 15 شهرا كانت
كفيله وكافيه لاظهار صحه رؤيته رغم ترحيب
المسؤولين الباكستانيين الباكستانيين
وقتها بسيطره طالبان استخدمت الاراضي
الافغانيه للضرب اهداف في باكستان ومنها
اماكن على الحدود هل هذا سبب تصاعد التوتر
اذا
باكستان متهما بنظري طالبا الافغانيه سمحت
للمسيرات الامريكيه في استخدام مجالها
الجوي لاختراق الاجواء الافغانيه والاتهام
جاء تحديدا بعد عمليه اغتيال زعيم تنظيم
القاعده ايمن الظواهري في اغسطس الماضي
ولتتصاعد بعدها حده الهجمات هجمات طالبان
باكستان على الحدود وهنا يتوجب على
الحكومه الباكستانيه الرد على هذا التصعيد
هناك تاثيرا للاوضاع في افغانستان هي
طالوا باكستان وزير الدفاع الباكستانيه
التي ذكرناها قبل قليل باكستان امام ضروره
مواجهه طالبه الهدنه الهشاشه الحركه هي
العقبه الكبرى امام التعاون الامني بين
كابل واسلام اباد عليه اقر التسامح في
نهايه العام الماضي اولا قانون للام
الوطني لمواجهه طالبان وكانت نتيجته منذ
ذلك الوقت عمليه عسكريه ضد طالبان باكستان
داخل الاراضي الافغانيه وعلى الحدود ومن
اجل هذه المواجهه عين قائد جديد للجيش قبل
شهر الجنرال عاصم منير يعتبره
الباكستانيون الامل في مواجهه الحركه بسبب
خبراته لاستخبراته العسكريه وفهمه لطبيعه
طالبا باكستان لكن اسلام اباد لن تكون
وحيده في هذه المواجهه واشنطنطينيه
امجد على قوائم الارهاب رسالته وتهديدا
مباشره اخرى من الولايات المتحده جاءت
اليسا باكستان في الولايات المتحده
والعهده على زعيم حركه طالبا باكستان نور
والي محسود وهذا يعني ان المشاركه
الامريكيه في ضربات على الحركه وقادتها
امر وارد سيناري الظواهري ليس ببعيد تحاول
طالبان منذ سيطرتها على البلاد الحصول على
الاعتراف الدولي لكن
وعودها جعل دولا عده ترفض اطفاء الشرعيه
السياسه الخارجيه بالطبع سبب لكن سياستها
الداخليه